dès le premier regard de l'ampleur de
cette bourse aux jouets agricole
surprend pour voir vendre ou acquérir
des miniatures agricoles il n'y a pas
mieux en france que le salon de chartres
on a une surface de 5000 m² avec 250
exposants qui vont diviser en trois
pôles un tiers de vendeurs
professionnels un tiers de vendeurs en
particulier et un tiers de zones de
dioramas qui représentent des scènes
agricole de tous les jours et la papauté
une manifestation comme ça on a un
public qui vient de tout horizon donc il
ya des gens qui n'ont jamais vu de
l'agriculture et là ils vont découvrir
un monde agricole vont poser des
questions et vont repartir avec une
haute idée du monde agricole ce soir
dans les allées les visiteurs se ruent
sur les pièces manquantes à leur
collection la fièvre de la chasse en
part de tous parfois de façon
déraisonnable on a 2 tonnes à lisier
pour aujourd'hui très beaux modèles je
suis exploitants chez forcément du
matériel ça me permet de l'avoir en
modèle réduit dans le salon du coup on
se limite à chartes parce que autrement
ça pourrait toute l'année tellement
agréable
non là on avait pris 200 250 euros un
budget non négligeable façon parce que
souvent le moindre
j'essaie toujours aux 50 60 euros m
et depuis que j'accumule ça fait quand
même un beau budget
et puis il y a les artistes les
créateurs de dioramas ces scènes de la
vie agricole reconstitué à l'échelle 1
32e des collectionneurs à la fois
profondément amoureux et nostalgiques
j'ai commencé à 12 ans j'ai commencé à
garder un peu plus cassée mais jouer et
je les ai encore ils sont une vitrine et
quand je passe devant l'industrie je
vous aime toujours c'est ça qui me fait
plaisir c'est que je me dis que il ya 30
ans ou 35 ans de passer mais c'est
toujours beau et voilà c'était c'est des
bons souvenirs j'ai cherché sans en vélo
et 10 km avec l'argent de poche que
j'avais à travailler dans les fermes
et puis j'ai jamais arrêté
avant la période qu'ovide ce salon
recevait près de 5000 visiteurs en une
seule journée ce dimanche en dépit du
pass sanitaires plus de trois mille
passionnés sont retombés en enfance